And we already live.
Yeah.
Damn.
Watch me tweet and talk at the same time.
You know there's a lot of
guitar players that can do that.
Tweet and guitar.
Yeah,
they can sing and talk at the same time.
Me,
I can't even type and talk at the same
time and I don't have to keep any kind of
spelled experience wrong.
Do you sing and talk at the same time?
It seems like sing,
sing and play guitar at the same time.
But they'll also play guitar and like
could he keep playing the song and then
talk to you about some something?
You know what I mean?
Like,
like I know man,
when you get down they need to make up
left and they're still playing the exact,
you know,
some of their,
their brain can,
can do both at the same time.
It's like drummers,
I don't get that.
Like a drummer has like
one beat on one leg,
one beat on the other leg.
How God damn impressive.
His diocese,
kid Max is a fucking beast.
Really?
Oh my God,
Dude.
We had Max Silverstein.
He came on the show with dice and we
played a video of it and I had seen him do
it live when we went to
dicer show cause he does,
he does like the,
his band does a song
before dice comes out.
So I knew that the kid
could play the drums,
but there's a video of him at the comedy
lab next to the Improv and who show was
it on a,
I don't know,
whatever it was,
the fucking kids and sane.
I mean,
he's not just good at the drums.
He's sick.
I mean he's,
he's,
it looks like a fucking professional.
Really?
Oh,
it's amazing man.
The hand eye coordination is ridiculous.
I mean,
he fucking goes off on
this solo and he nails it.
He nails it perfect.
And it's one of those,
one of those moments,
you're like,
that kid's a bad mother fucker.
That kid could be a bad
motherfucker at anything he wants.
He wants his fucking dad
did a great job raising him,
man.
That,
that kid loves his father.
You know,
that is a beautiful thing to
watch Dyson as kid for real.
He loves his fucking kids,
man.
And they love him and
they're all empowered.
Like his son is super confident,
young and strong and smart and you know,
he's,
he's fucking got a real shot,
a real shot,
you know,
without anybody's help.
Just from talent,
just from the,
you know,
the,
the ability to play drums like that.
You can do that.
I really believe you could
apply that shit to anything.
And if you go to a on it
and use the coupon code,
Rogan it yourself.
So Alpha brain,
and they learned to
function on my level son.
So seamless people will make
fun of me for this Alpha brain.
But you can all go fuck yourself if you
take it and you don't see any results.
I think there's something wrong with your
brain needed to go to a doctor and you
could find out or you need to
get that from I Tommy buns.
He just held up his
arms and shut his wrong.
She's throwing phones
around this rappels apples.
It's really a fucking
guns around this room.
Ah,
no.
So for,
for Real,
what is Alpha brain?
It's really the,
it's all bad.
It's best explained on,
on at.com cause it was written
by sober people first of all.
And second of all,
people who understand science other
than my level of understanding,
which is repeating shit that
other people understand,
but I don't ever really understand.
He believes in evolution.
Um,
well I think there is certainly a lot
of evidence for natural selection and
adaptation and that it's most
likely the way things have evolved,
but there's some holes in it.
There's some holes.
Yeah,
we'll talk about it.
Kind of a question for talking about this.
The middle of a commercial.
Hey Man.
Well I thought this way,
this ship roles here,
I want to thank God it's Icom for
supporting us while we got hacked recently
folks.
And uh,
we uh,
had to like severely upgrade our,
uh,
her um,
technical system,
whoever it is that the
website interfaces with.
Uh,
I learned something new
passwords.
If you use like a regular word as
a password and it may be a number,
you know,
that's okay.
But the hardest thing
that would take like,
I forget like 32 years for a computer
to hack is if you just take three random
words and put them together,
like Taco fart handicap
or something like that.
Yeah.
And that way the computer will never just
the odds that we'll get to that point,
it was like 32.
Well yeah,
but then they'll just have a new computer
search engine and now they were like,
yeah,
what bitch?
And they'll nail it quick or we just
got the capital and lowercase thing.
I don't think that matters like zero.
Most things aren't case sensitive.
Yeah.
But uh,
either way on it.com spelled o and n I
t and if you go there and today is the
11th,
September 11th.
And uh,
if you go there for one more day,
use the code,
got your back and you get
18% off of everything.
That includes kettle bells and battle
ropes because normally the coupon,
a coupon code of Rogan only
works for the supplements.
It doesn't work for the kettle
bells in the battle ropes.
The reason being is that we sell
those literally as cheapest as humanly
possible,
but because of this fuck up,
because the fact that everybody feels
terrible that this website got hacked.
The,
we don't know whether or not anybody's a
credit card information got compromised
so far.
No one has a reported any what
they call substantiated fraud,
I think they call it,
but uh,
whatever it is,
some scumbags figured out a
way to get into our system.
It's just,
I don't understand the way they do it.
I completely talking like I'm
explaining French to you though.
I don't speak French so I
could never really comment.
But as far as I know,
I mean it's really,
I think for a lot of these guys it's fun
to see how they can sneak into systems
even if the not stealing anything.
I think script kids that are just really
bright and they figured out how to
sneak into your system.
It's all against the hunt man.
They're like trying to see how far they
can get it and then you have to some
hacker.
Is she the other day?
What'd you do?
I'll talk poll.
Let me,
yeah,
let me just get through with this.
So because of that,
because everybody's very bummed
out about that and that you're,
uh,
you know,
the credit card information has been
compromised and if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash breach,
it'll explain all that.
It's just an unfortunate aspect
of doing business on the Internet.
We apologize and nobody,
uh,
nobody foresaw it this way.
Uh,
we've beefed up the security considerably,
so hopefully it won't happen again.
Whoever hacked this,
please don't do that.
Thanks.
You don't have to do that.
That's mean,
I know you can do it.
Okay.
We know you can do it.
Please don't do it.
I don't want anybody to get caught and
go to jail for something stupid like
that.
And you know,
and if that's how you're
making your money,
how dare you go get a
fucking respectable job.
You son of a bitch,
you're stealing numbers from offline.
You can't do that.
I'm a big fan of you guys.
Whoever you are,
I want to give a shout
out Favell shout outs.
So anonymous.
Well,
sec shout out right out to
the hackers of the world.
Yeah,
man,
look that,
you know,
there's a certain,
there's a certain amount of morals that
are on the Internet when it comes to how
things get done as well.
You know,
there's,
there's a,
there's a moral attitude at the Internet
and then I think more mirror society
than it does.
Uh,
the shit that you see on television,
the shade that you see in the news,
you know,
there's a link when anything goes down.
The difference between like,
Dan,
we shouldn't do this in a commercial.
Joe Joe rogan.net.
That's my website.
Go to [inaudible] dot
com use the other phone.
You know,
that's not for today though.
Do not sponsor us to that.
That
it's only a part time
thing with the thing.
We're just trying it out.
Seeing how it works is the phone.
It's phenomenal though that Samsung
Galaxy s three is fucking is to shit.
It's really sweet.
It's sexy.
It's amazing.
It's really great.
It's got a little for
you every now and then.
A little hiccup here and there,
but it's really special.
I needed to phone.
It's a special phone.
What's the queefs about?
It wasn't it?
And it just seems like I'm,
I think they're,
the iPhone is a really well
designed phone man tomorrow.
The way it is it tomorrow
the light comes out,
the way the,
the,
the touch screen first of all is
better than anything on the planet.
They're the best touchscreen.
The quality of it feels
better than anything.
Like when you'd have the case on an iPhone
and you just feel that knowing glass,
it's like the sexiest
piece of equipment ever.
But you got to walk around
with a condom on it because,
you know,
it's so breakable.
But,
but it's still super duper fucking sexy.
I mean,
hold on to that thing.
I mean feel that that's
a genius piece of device.
And so it's,
that phone is to always a little
better than everything I've tried.
The way it interfaces,
just cleaner,
smarter makes more sense,
easier to find shit.
It's just better.
It's like our Tiffany jewelry,
my phone really started taking
a shit the most today really.
And it's totally because it comes out
to my apple sending out electronic.
The Joe Rogan experience is brought
to you by on a.com going Oh,
and it,
we've got to get this podcast start,
this ridiculous.
That's it.
We're not brought to you by anyone else.
Go to death squad.tv though,
and pick up some,
some funky sexy cat shirts.
It has been proven that you are 20% more
likely to get your penis touch if you
weren't a desk.
What captured 20% 43% with alcohol.
You add a desk,
squad shirt and alcohol,
and someone's going to touch your penis.
And this is a blind study.
Yeah,
it's like three out of five times
someone's touching your penis.
Okay.
All right.
I feel good for you.
I feel like the odds are strong.
Thompson Gore is here.
You dirty bitches.
Let's get it.
Poppin Brian Experience.
Oh,
sweetness.
Tommy buns in the fucking house.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's Tommy like it's
good to have you buddy.
We were about to,
uh,
just talk nonsense and go through
commercial and Tommy buns hits me with,
do you believe in evolution?
Thrown heavy handed question.
That's so fucking right hand
bombed the open the round.
Well it's just funny to me cause I was
watching this thing about and this guy
was like,
this guy I can believe in evolution
should be taught in the classrooms and it
was like a political ad like that.
Like that that appeals to somebody.
They're like,
yeah,
fuck that guy.
He thinks evolution be fucking asshole.
You're like,
really?
There's that.
There's actually enough
people that believe like I,
I'm not a science expert so I
don't want anyone to think like,
wait a minute,
you're about to,
you're not a science expert.
I know.
I mean I know.
What price point do you become an expert
because if you were just you and you
lived in the 14 hundreds
you'd be a fucking science x.
You're probably right.
They'd be like,
electricity is God's way
of showing you his anger.
You're like,
well no,
actually it's just some shit that's
formed by from the lives of the atmosphere
and my president.
You'd be a fucking scientist.
You could explain so much
shit to these people.
Well actually I would just know it
and not know how to explain it though.
Would just be like,
no,
you drive,
you drive round.
And they'd be like,
how have you known?
I'd be like,
just cousins scene.
You would,
you would work with those people for a
couple of days and you'd be so annoyed.
You're like,
listen,
you have to listen to me.
I'm your new king and I'm going to
show you how to build an airplane.
They'd be like an airplane.
What the fuck you talking about?
Get some,
get someone I'm going to show you you
need this has gotta be straight like that.
Think like a bird.
But then with the tail up in the air
air draft from above and below you go to
go.
Where did you get this idea from?
I Dunno man.
They just come to me to just come to me.
You draw like bows and arrows for like
Davinci was like from the future and went
to the past.
I think the Davinci too many ideas.
You know what people love to say
when there's a guy like Davinci,
they go and I wanted to sit,
just say it just of instinct.
It's probably had like
Asperger's or something.
They always want to say
something like that.
Like that.
There's no way you could be close off
with that guy that brilliant and not be
fucked up.
Like I'm not willing to believe it,
you know?
I don't think that,
I mean keeping like,
I almost agree that like I don't think
you could go to Davinci and be like,
how do you like your eggs man?
And He'd be like,
you know,
actually like I think he would be
talking about all kinds of weird shit.
Like thinking about what you would look
like if you cleaved you in half and
pulled,
you could draw those two sides.
You want to donate your body
like today and you're like,
no.
And I dead yet.
Did you ever see that exhibit,
that bodyworks exhibit where
they take human bio together?
Yeah,
that's right.
It's crazy.
It is creepy as fuck dude.
And they were stopping us
from taking pictures over.
They told us to put our phones away.
I had to take camera and
pictures on the sneak tip.
Yeah.
We're like,
no,
flash a horse.
Remember the horse,
they had this like real horse.
It had been like,
well,
what was fucked up was
that if you did this,
if you haven't seen it,
folks,
the body works exhibit is a in the exhibit
where they take a bunch of death dead
bodies and through some new method of uh,
somehow or another coating them with
plastic and then fusing plastic into the
muscles.
It doesn't change the appearance,
but it completely stops
them from decaying.
So it's really creepy.
They give you the different acts years.
Yeah,
so they give you like a portion.
Yeah.
That's what's really fucked up is the
clinical aspect of the dissection of the
bodies on display was a little disturbing
because it was almost like butcher
ask.
It's like if this was a guy's basement,
you would want him locked up forever.
Okay.
This guy would be one of the most horrific
serial killers and twisted fox ever.
Ever.
Even if it was a grave
robber and he did this,
you would want this
motherfucker locked up forever,
but you can do it and somehow
because you've involved plastic,
which means that it's been like
government sanctioned or something.
Now you can just display these dead
bodies and people can come and pay.
Like how,
where did you get these bodies?
Exactly.
And all you need.
It's not even like under heavy scrutiny
of some of them had like bullet wounds
or something.
Does that exhibit even still around?
It's got a smell by now.
The one that I saw,
I saw it in Vegas.
Um,
it was at,
I think it was luck.
Sore.
Yeah.
And um,
and too much sadness for one day at the
end they said that all the bodies in
that exhibit were from China.
Yeah.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's scary because when you're,
when you're from a country that has been
known to do some really horrific things
to like prisoners and Shit,
pretty questionable track record
when it comes to human rights.
Well,
there doesn't seem to be that
there's that many of them in China.
And so it's,
I mean,
uh,
or rather that there's too many of them
in China and there's so many people that
in some areas the overpopulation,
it's gotten to a point where they've
sort of devalued life and a lot of,
I mean,
when you start hearing
the stories about them,
you know,
forcing them to only have one child.
And so this terrible stories
of families drowning,
uh,
Chinese girls,
it's really horrific because
they want a boy fucking crazy.
And you know,
if that's propaganda though.
So I really honestly shouldn't be,
well outside of like,
outside of the major cities,
there's a lot of like extra
like out in the countryside,
which is hundreds of millions of people,
there's extreme poverty,
there's extreme literacy.
There's,
you know,
there's not any healthcare or anything.
It's just the hundreds of millions of
people outside of the major cities.
When you,
I mean that kind of poor,
I mean we have the,
we just haven't figured that out yet.
I don't,
I don't think most Americans are
really like put that into their head.
Like that level,
the level of poverty that
exists in other countries.
We have extreme poverty,
but it's,
you know,
there's,
it's not like really what you see.
Yeah.
In third we have horrific poverty,
but even just existing in a welfare
state is way better than a giant chunk of
the world has access to.
You know,
if you think about like what,
what it would be like if you just had a
shit roll the dice and you wound up in
Nigeria.
Yeah.
You're a baby in Nigeria and it's just
flies and mosquitoes and malaria is,
and a dude's got a Hyena
on a chain and you're like,
what the fuck would you,
most of Africa is fucking crazy.
Really wild,
crazy place man.
I just got back from there.
Did you really?
Just in South Africa.
Oh that's right.
You were doing gigs out there.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was so cool.
People were so nice.
Crowds were fucking awesome.
And then I met other Africans that
were in South Africa and I learned like
that's the destination.
Like if you live in Botswana,
Mozambique,
Namibia,
you go like I want to go to South Africa.
That's the,
that is the crown jewel of it.
Cause that's the most
developed like by far,
by far,
by far.
And like when I was in,
uh,
I was in the casino walking through
it with this comic who is from,
I think he was from a former,
what is he from?
He's from Nigeria or somewhere,
I don't know.
Mozambique,
I think.
And I was like,
uh,
so what's like,
you know your country?
Like he was like,
man,
he's like,
you,
you know how you picture Africa?
And I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
that's what it's like.
Like it's fucking open terrain
and animals and tribal shit.
And he goes,
this shit right here.
The casino,
the only thing like this in my
country is like where the king lives.
What if that too,
there's no shit like this at all.
That's going to be so weird to have one
city that's like on top of the ball and
everything else.
It's just as bad.
Barely keeping it to air.
They're barely keeping it together.
Yeah,
it was.
Um,
but it was,
it was a,
it was an awesome experience.
People were the crowds,
like so good,
very like mixed crowds and
just juiced for the shows.
I mean,
I would say out of 15 black
coat jokes go fucking killed.
They understand American black humor.
Totally.
They got it.
They totally get it.
And they got it.
They got everything.
You got everything man.
Wow.
Um,
did you find,
did you find them to be like,
um,
into like harsh material or they just,
it was interesting.
All the,
the local guys,
we saw a bunch of some South African
comics and a lot of them are,
have very political material and
because it's a very politically charged
atmosphere,
you know,
you think about that,
like they got democracy in
94 so it's Kinda like us,
you know,
you just fast forward like,
like the 60s and seventies really
politically charged in America.
Right.
And then right.
And then,
you know,
there's just like,
it's fresh.
So that's what everybody talks about.
They talk about politics
and things going on,
but it's like South African politics.
And then we go in and we'll
talk about the mundane,
like just silly,
like observational shit.
And some of the local guys were saying
that like that's so unusual for them.
Like to that somebody would just talk
about some like small observation they
made because it's all about making an
impact with like your observation about
what's really going on in the
world or in the country right now.
You know,
so everybody's a preacher.
I mean there's a lot.
He said that,
look,
you can go to like a,
you can do it,
go to a standup show in South Africa,
that's all locals and they'll
all hit on political shit.
He said that's not uncommon at all.
That's interesting.
Is it funny?
Did you find it funny?
There's this guy,
David cow is a South African comic
and he was fucking tremendous.
Yeah.
I didn't even know what like,
he was like,
you know when somebody really good and
you don't necessarily get the reference
but you laugh anyways.
Like you don't even,
you're like,
you don't know,
like I don't even know what that was.
Right,
right,
right.
You still laugh just cause he's
just timing and it's funny.
It was like that fucking
devastated the place.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean he was so,
but he was all like,
it was all about south,
like current shit in South Africa.
Wow.
And it was like,
it was wonder if that would translate
like if he did the u s I think he,
I don't think it would,
I don't think the act would,
but I think he's good enough where he
would just need to just figure it out.
That was something that never
happened with the Boston guys.
There was a bunch of guys from Boston
that Boston like no other place does like
local material.
Like my first 20 minutes was all local
material because you knew it would work.
It was like almost like it was first of
all there was a lot of really funny shit
about Boston and people from
Boston love laughing about Boston.
Yeah.
So that like everybody that
was like really strong had
such a Boston centric act
like Steve Sweeney in Boston.
I'll put him up there with the greatest
standup performances of all time.
I'm telling you,
Steve Sweeney in Boston in the 80s,
you to lay them down,
do just boom,
like he was Boland strikes crushing with
this Boston material and he's just such
a funny guy.
He just such a funny guy
and he had been through the,
like the hard Boston club scene,
you know,
over a decade before I ever saw him.
You know what I mean?
He's just,
he was just a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
And that guy,
you know,
when he would go to California,
he would lose like a big chunk of his
act because he couldn't talk about that
shit anymore.
It was so frustrating to me.
It was like,
man,
you could do that about anything.
If you could hit that level of comedy,
he could do that with anything.
Yeah.
That's the thing
that we all,
everybody thought this by the way.
We'd all,
cause I was there,
Christina was on the show
to a finesse Mitchell,
Ian Bagg,
uh,
Mitch Fatel,
Brian Haner and we all
watched David and we're like,
he just goes to states why?
And fucking like,
you know,
he needed to work like
kind of week after week.
Right.
And just if he did that
for just a few months,
he would put together
a stellar fucking act.
I'm sure.
Well,
I think now,
especially because of the Internet,
the guys that are coming up over the
next 10 years has a lot of good guys.
Yeah.
And I think that a lot of these
good young up and coming stands up,
the standups have had a chance to see
so many good acts online so that even if
in their,
in their area and their
area is not so good.
You know,
like there's all,
I'm Roman mentioning names,
but there's some places
you'll go and like,
oh he's the funniest local guy.
You should have him open for you and
you have the guy open for you and he's
fucking deaf.
Just nonsense and just bad
hacky tricks and you're like,
oh cow.
Riced but if you're in that community,
all you really need a stage time.
If you've got like access to,
you know,
you can watch the,
the Kinison archives,
he could see bill Hicks stuff.
She could see Stan hope.
You can see David Tell,
he could see Norton,
you could see all these
different comics online.
You could sort of get
at what do you enjoy,
what do you enjoy?
I know you don't enjoy it,
what that guy's doing.
So instead of thinking about like the
hacky stuff that's in your neighborhood,
you have access to all this stuff.
Whereas like in this,
the 80s when I started out,
there was no access to that other
than like cds and cassettes.
It wasn't as immediate and it was more,
it was way more difficult to
sort of create a scene or to,
you know,
to,
to get good without like
a good scene around you.
Yeah.
You know,
I think,
cause I always feel like I'm only as good
as the guys that I see around me on a
regular basis and the guys that
I performed with other basis.
Yeah.
So if you were stuck somewhere where
you don't see a lot of good shit,
it definitely would affect your game.
Yeah.
Because like when I see
someone really good,
like when someone's stand
hopes in town or when a,
I see ds go up and kill or you know,
a towel or some,
you know,
someone I really respect
and I see their act,
I get so charged up,
uh,
it gives me energy to make things.
Yeah,
it definitely is.
Yeah.
That,
that little juice,
that little,
the little squirt of just
some push to get you forward.
You know,
that's so important for nothing.
Like seeing great staying at when you
were standing up and you see somebody
great at the show you're
at and you're like,
fuck,
I'm not a fan of
watching stand up.
Like I like when I'm at the comedy clubs,
I tried not to watch anybody.
I don't watch a lot of standup,
but I do like if the,
if I know there's somebody
either I want to see,
you know,
or somebody I know and I'm like,
oh,
like a friend of mine
or somebody who's like,
you know,
this person's really good.
I don't sit through a whole
shows but I'll watch that person.
And sometimes it is like,
man,
that's fucking so exciting.
You get pumped up about it.
You're like,
that's awesome.
You get like,
um,
like it makes you want to work.
I could watch Joey Diaz do a
thousand sets in a row probably.
Well yeah there's definitely
certain people but like if I'm like,
you know,
at the Improv or whatever,
the ice house and there's like
all these comics going up,
I would not,
I don't like sitting there watching
them cause it seems like to me it just,
it,
I'm too scared of going there and then
having that like something in the back of
my head from somebody else or
it seems like that's really,
I get it.
I get anxiety when I,
when I sit around I'm just watching like,
uh,
just comic after comic home,
not get anxiety.
I get like,
man,
I can't sit here right now.
Like,
I just get like,
I'm like,
I got,
I got to get up,
I got to,
I can't sit through this if I think it's
like if I sit and that's like a minute
in and I'm like,
ah,
this is not going to be,
this is not good.
I have to get up and leave.
You can't watch do it.
So you can watch like Louis
C K for fucking hours,
but you can't watch a bunch of like,
can't I want to say any names?
But there's a certain
group of people that,
you know,
you've,
you've seen them do standup and
you never going to understand it,
but yet there's still bumping around
and you might like be in the back of the
room one day and they're on stage and you,
you almost have a heart
attack bucking up and out.
You got to get out of the room.
They'll in fact you,
I think,
yeah,
they will.
Well,
do you know this real thought behind?
That sounds crazy,
but it's,
um,
there's a schizophrenia,
something happens to schizophrenia and I
believe it's called Alef Renea and it's
a,
um,
a very rare situation where people will
go to visit crazy people and become
crazy while they visited them.
Really?
Yeah.
And um,
they don't know.
They don't know exactly what it is
and they think it might be for mono,
it might be,
um,
might be something in the way
you interact with this person.
But it has happened before where people
have gone in to visit people who are
fucking crazy and they,
all of a sudden people were like,
we're going to have to keep
an eye on you and then boom.
So it's just like almost by like
the association with that person.
But it could be that they were
just always crazy as fuck.
Nobody without,
or you're with them.
It's almost like when you,
what's it called when you like
Stockholm Syndrome where you start to,
you start,
I think that's what guys
with your kid matters.
Yeah.
But I mean like it's like you,
there's a certain exposure to that person
that starts to affect your like on a
deeper level.
I don't know enough about how
affect each other to really,
when I was in college,
I was in psych one o one our teacher
one day we were talking about,
you know,
you're going through all the basics and
then he gets to schizophrenia and he was
like,
okay,
he writes it on the board and he's like,
schizophrenia is the worst thing
that could ever happen to you.
And then this kid in his class and our
class raised his hand and he's like,
Yup.
And he's like,
I have schizophrenia.
I don't think it's the worst
thing that could ever happen.
And we were all like,
oh,
you're just pissed off
the schizophrenia guy.
And then he's like,
well,
what I meant was there are different
stages of schizophrenia and that the worst
one is the worst thing
that could happen to you.
Which one do you have?
Like do you have?
And he's like,
ah,
I have like a less like,
you know,
severe.
And he was like,
Oh yeah,
that's not what I meant.
But Nice.
It'd be really bad if I to back pedal.
I'm trying to find the name of this,
uh,
this thing that,
that we're,
we're,
it's happened before,
so the rare case of people
who've visited schizophrenia,
but I can't,
I can't seem to find,
so I might,
I might be talking a little bit of Shit
because I'm just repeating some things
that I think it was,
I think it was Terence Mckenna,
it turns from Canada lecturer.
But,
um,
the idea was that I'm,
one of the things that they think about
some people when they start to lose
their mind is that,
um,
it,
it becomes a,
a pheromonal problem when they're giving
off this weird smell to people like
this,
uh,
um,
what does,
uh,
you know,
how would you describe a fair
amount of hormonal smell,
I guess?
And people treat them.
We're there.
It's a fence.
Offensive.
People treat them odd
and they start thinking,
why am I on,
am I crazy?
And that,
that tipping point is like really
not that hard to do on some people.
Really.
Yeah.
Because if you think about
how you interact with people,
I'm sure you've had times in your life
where you've been a is socially awkward
or you felt like real weird.
It felt like real vulnerable
little special when you were young.
Brian,
barely.
You barely feel get one correct
sentence yesterday with Kat von d.
Come on that I looked over.
He came in his pants three times.
It's like,
how are you doing today so far?
I keep on thinking about it.
Beautiful.
I met with me,
I saw a picture of you
hugging her was just like,
you're just in bliss.
He look like,
he was like,
I'm actually touching her.
I liked girls that think like that.
Like the energy thing she said about,
you know,
I love girls that think like that.
That's a very nice person and
she's incredibly artistic.
She's a bad ass bitch so many fast.
She was really nice too,
man.
She's really nice,
like legit Nice,
like not a bullshit.
Nice.
Just a nice person.
Yeah.
It's nice when you see someone
that's trying to do that,
that's trying to do the right thing.
Yeah.
It was rather bro.
Where did you get that from?
From Kevin d from watching how she talks.
I think so.
Well,
we're trying to hit you.
Don't you don't think Kat von D is Hot?
Are you saying something?
Like I said,
I watched her show look.
Yo Man,
sounds like to me.
Do it again,
but look me in the eyes.
Red Ban is that are um,
impression for everybody.
Like what?
Spiderman sound like
sticky in my head.
That's it.
It's sucky.
Impression do.
That's terrible.
That was fucking spot on.
Really?
Yeah.
Deeper crashing.
No,
I'm a big fan of Kat von D.
I watched every episode of that show.
Really?
Absolutely.
I see Eddie Bravo episode.
Probably missed that one,
but the other ones I caught.
Why it's me,
man.
What's it must be the ringtone.
Fucking a t and t commercial.
You gave me shit about mine
too because I have on that.
I have the same thing.
Why I don't change turn.
I just want to know if someone's calling.
Okay.
That's all I want to know,
Brian.
I don't really give a fuck what it,
Sandy,
I love you.
Hello Brian.
Hey stop him.
He's taking your girl.
That's not cool.
You said Kat von d I love you.
That's so not cool.
You,
you don't understand what it was
like for Little Bri yesterday.
Really horrible.
You want to hear my new ringtone is a cat?
Yes.
Okay.
Stop that.
He's terrible man.
You really need to find out what happened
to you that froze you in 12 did you
spend some time with schizophrenia?
Like yesterday?
There was some strange moment when
you were 12 and you just stuck their
emotional life in that ring tone.
How do you even know if it's your phone?
If it's ringing?
I don't give a fuck.
Just check.
How about that?
How about I don't give a fuck,
right?
You should sell ringtones man,
cause I was going through the ringtones
store and that the top 10 ones are so
dumb.
Like snakes.
Unicorn was the best one
and I was just really stone.
But there's like one that's just like a
black eye going yo man into your phone.
That's what I want.
I want a white guy doing
a bad black guy to,
if you were in like a really black
area and you hear the phone go right,
no phone,
motherfucker
pick up y'all phone bed.
You don't think my impression
of a blackboard turn right.
Just think it was over.
It was okay.
It was a little racist
kids
lately.
I only said that.
I only said that because it
was the funniest thing to say.
Okay.
Um,
I don't think you're racist by
any stretch of the imagination,
but I did.
I put on myself,
I put what some people thought
was a racist tweet the other day.
I wrote a,
I saw a black,
I would admit Romney
bumper sticker on his car.
I go to the mines were right.
This fucking thing is over.
Yeah.
Like that.
That's ridiculous.
Is Black and white racist piece of shit.
And all of a sudden people were
saying on a racist piece of shit.
How is that racist?
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't know enough about Mitt Romney to
know if there was a joke in there about
him in black people or what.
My question is what black guys are
relating to Mitt Romney or here?
I mean that's going to
get you some more tweets.
I need to look.
I wish there was another alternative
because I'm not really happy with either
one of these guys.
This is,
it seems silly to me.
I mean,
uh,
I feel like socially Obama's way better,
the way he communicates his battery,
he's way smarter.
He's way more moderate,
more way more reasonable.
They're hanging out with way
more impressive fuck Yad.
Where the Obama [inaudible]
out is that seems like fuck,
look at all the shit that got
passed while Obama was in office.
I don't know how much of
that had to do with them.
It's so hard to believe that a young guy
just a few years older than me would be
so willing to give in to this ridiculous
idea that given the government more
power over the people is
necessary to keep us safe.
Cause I think that's
just total horse shit.
I just think they want to lock it down
and they're slowly eroding our rights and
they're doing it in a
very unconstitutional way.
And that's not the way to do your job.
Your job is to do it within
a constitutional way.
And if you,
you,
if you can't keep us safe
in a constitutional way,
it means you suck at your fucking job.
You need to get better at that.
But we don't need to do is look at
everybody's fucking email and listen to
everybody's voicemail messages and
track everybody's movement through GPS.
And you don't need to do all that.
This is crazy because who decides
who has access to that information?
Who Decides?
You know,
he,
the people could harass you because you
have different political beliefs than
them or you,
the,
your,
you know,
interrupting their campaign that,
this,
there's a lot of different things that
someone could do if they have influence,
if they have enough power over you by,
uh,
by being able to,
to,
to track your whereabouts
and listening to their all,
all your phone calls.
That shit is ridiculous.
And the fact that that's
happening in America,
man,
that's what we always used to make
fun of the Soviet Union about that,
you know,
everything.
Everybody was being a spy.
And spied on.
And we never thought that
shit was going on over here.
And then meanwhile the government just
opens up the floodgates and it's all of
us and now it's so gross.
And that didn't you retweet that somebody,
I didn't even know about this.
And it amazes me that the,
that this happens and
nobody knows that they,
they audited the Fed and that they
find out that like the bailout,
um,
amounts,
we're not even close.
It was trillions of dollars
in secret Bayley's bail outs.
And then certain companies
were getting trillions,
not brilliant.
Not even like what we were told
they were getting like with say,
50 billion,
you're like,
Jesus,
you've got 50 billion now.
They got like one point $3 trillion.
Yeah,
it's insane.
And that was like,
uh,
the,
like it was in the news,
but like I feel like nobody really,
they were like,
oh yeah,
so what happened?
I don't get it,
man.
I don't,
I don't understand how any of it flies.
It's the,
I mean,
the whole idea that you get that,
first of all,
the whole idea that the only way to fix
all this shit has to take more money
from office fucking preserve.
That is so bonkers.
That's the stupidest idea ever.
It's like you're telling
me that you just have to,
no matter what,
keep these defense budgets
the way they are now.
That's what they're saying
essentially is saying,
look,
we're not going to shrink that.
So let's just concentrate on who it along.
Why can some things off and some other,
it's this giant chunk.
Our money's being thrown at
this ridiculous situation,
this horrific situation rather.
And now I can't fix that.
That is just what it is.
You know?
We'll cut that a little bit.
We're going to cut that a little bit.
We got no money for
pizza in school though.
You know,
it's,
uh,
the idea that,
you know,
when you're gonna need a
little bit more from everybody,
like,
no,
you don't.
You need to stop spending money on shit
that we don't want you to spend money
on.
What the fuck?
Where's the money going?
And nobody.
The thing is like not only defense,
but nobody is ever really
willing to make confessions.
Nobody wants to give up whatever their
cause is or whatever their committee,
they sit on,
just go somewhere else.
So you end up finding a group of people
that are all agreeing to not make any,
any deals like no,
just take from somebody else,
just not us.
And it goes around the circle
and then you'd go like,
all right,
that was fun.
Fucking nobody made
any concessions at all.
First of all,
the only way we're gonna fix this whole
world problem as we're going to have to
be able to read each other's minds.
People are just too full of shit.
Language is just one step on an ever
ending or never ending rather process of,
of getting closer and closer
to each other languages,
uh,
the ability to do it and expression and
you say what you s you comes out of your
mouth.
I know what you're saying.
I know who you are.
You talk,
We're going to be able to get past that.
That's what the next step is.
The next step is we're going to be able
to read each other's minds and until
then we're going to have a really hard
time with this fucking thing because
people were full of shit and people
misinterpret people's words and people are
touchy and people don't know why they're
really mad and you know there's a lot
of the problems with what normal
human communication and part of it is,
I can only gauge your
intent like guesswork.
I can only gauge your intent by how you,
how you respond,
guesswork and,
and,
and then you put it into the computer
that is your brain and try to figure out
if this person is good for my life
as personally bad for my life,
is this person,
my friend,
and they're looking out for me.
Eventually we're going to
just read each other's minds.
That's all going to be bullshit.
And you're going to know who's
a consequent consequently
know the cons to going
to have to straighten up.
It's going to be like a beautiful moment.
Yeah.
But you're also gonna know,
you know,
all the creepy shit about
people we're getting,
we're going to definitely get past the
idea that the only way I can communicate
is through some noise,
some mouth noise and some text
messages looking at somebody you think,
well,
look at the interface of text messaging.
I mean,
look at how that's already got your,
you've already got this
new way to communicate with
people that are nowhere near
you.
Yeah.
You know,
so you're,
you're getting a little
bit of their information,
a little bit of their personality,
a little bit of their mind,
this little text that's
coming in on your phone.
Yeah.
Well eventually that's gonna it's
gonna Morph into the next thing.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's going to be people that let you
ride along where you could tap into their
consciousness and you could
walk around with them and shit.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't see that being outside
of the realm of possibility.
I think that's totally possible that you
could eventually get to a point where a
person interfaces with some sort
of an internet connection in,
um,
it may be some,
some sort of,
something that you would wear on your
head that stimulates various parts of the
brain with electrical impulses or
something that can trigger certain
experiences.
If they figured out how
to really wire that,
maybe they'll actually have to fucking
drill some holes in your head and Shit
and put little little conductors
that you have to screw shit into.
But people would totally do it if
you could actually work that out.
Probably ride along with each other.
Yeah.
Look,
you could go,
uh,
you were a real fence
if you're a real freak,
you know,
like those dudes like
watching their wives,
fuck fuck other guys,
they get like be their wife while she
gets fucked by this giant black guy.
Yeah,
he's gotta be bad.
Cause that's the scariest big guys one.
But big black eyes.
The scariest or that's
maybe like what is thing?
It was not like cuckold,
is that what they call them guys and
like watching other guys to fuck their
wives in front of them.
That's,
that's interesting.
That's to me,
that's the real quick and that's
the exciting point for them.
They're like,
this guy's about to drill my wife,
this is fucking awesome.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Yep.
And they want,
they want her to get fucking hammered.
But how can that end in
anything other than murder,
suicide,
Kenneth?
I don't know.
But I was just thinking
you could never switch it.
You can never fuck a girl
in front of your wife.
And she's just sitting
there brushing her hair.
Really.
You know,
slow.
And I don't think so unless she was crazy.
But it's,
but it's not normal that a guy
would sit there and get off on that.
No,
it's not normal at all.
Some guys are just real freaks.
Yeah.
But there's everything,
you know,
I mean,
shit,
that's well put.
There's everything.
That really is what the answer is.
And we didn't really know that
as much when we were kids.
That's why you were subject
to get a costed by like,
uh,
some predator.
Yeah,
because you never knew any predators.
So we didn't,
we didn't have access to
nearly as much information.
The Internet really exposes fuck yeah.
Every kid knows about pedos
now we got a pedo bear,
you know,
I mean pedos weren't something
that everybody talked
about when I was a kid was
it was like you keep away from that man,
he's a bad man.
And He'd be like,
Oh,
who's the bad guy?
Bad Guy over there.
Why is he back by the partner
wise that nobody understood what,
how kids know now you have the files,
how many kinks there are.
Like there's all these,
you go on line sub categories
of shit and you're like,
that's a thing.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
there's exposed and instead
we're like adults now.
But you realize that like if you
look back on like fifth grade,
you,
he's aware that 10 year olds are online.
All these,
oh there's this shit.
There was always specialty things.
There was always like,
like,
but it was hard to find them.
Like if you were going to
be in a weird freak shit.
Yeah.
Like some dudes are in the feet.
And they were,
they were actual feet magazines.
Yeah.
Nice.
We,
I found a feet Porno
magazine with my friends.
I have it in the woods.
Oh,
okay.
We were wandering through the woods
and we found a pile of magazines,
like in a plastic bag.
If you found them in the woods,
there were almost 60% of
the time they were porn.
Right.
If you found a dude who went
to read magazines in the woods,
it was a lot of people that would go
and they would just go beat off in the
woods,
man.
Great.
I love that.
And dudes that go to read magazines and
they left their stash back there so we
will go find their stash.
And so it was me and
my two friends and uh,
as,
uh,
they were opening the,
the pages,
my front,
there were two,
one dues from Argentina.
They'll do was from Cuba.
Yeah.
And we're,
we're in Florida and we're peeling back
these pages and this kid stops and he
goes,
man,
I think this shit is just dicks and feet.
Okay.
Ah,
that's the quote of the day ladies.
And,
and it was one of the first times I had
ever saw anybody like so clearly say
what the fuck when they
don't really want an answer.
Right.
You know that,
you know when you say like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
And you don't really,
yeah.
It was just like,
what the fuck?
Like he knew,
I didn't know.
I knew he didn't know we were 11 or we're
looking at like dude's jerking off on,
yeah,
I guess a whole thing.
I've been wanting that to be a thing.
I didn't know it was,
I found the creepiest new
fetish I'll yesterday,
it's called belly punching.
Just guys and girls punching a other
girls in the belly really hard.
Really?
And they get off on it.
I don't want to watch that.
And the videos are just really disturbing.
I,
it's from Brazil.
You don't get that off.
Please shut that off.
That stuff bugs me.
I don't get off on it,
but I've seen it and it was like,
it was so extreme that I
was like in tears laughing.
What was it?
The ball kicking.
Oh Jeez.
But so I saw one,
I was like,
oh,
that's clearly that guy has a cup on,
you know,
like you can tell this one was genuine.
She was like,
she was kicking like 50 yard field.
It's like lining up and taking off.
And he was like,
ah,
his legs were shaking and then she's like,
yes,
suffer,
suffer and like fucking dude.
Fuck.
Is that about,
I don't know man.
But somebody like somebody who's
not watching that like to lap,
they're watching that.
That is the most erotic arousing thing.
I got kicked once so hard in a tournament.
I've been kicked many times when I get
kicked once in a tournament where my cops
slammed into my balls and it,
it Wa I was fucked up.
My,
my ball swole up,
they were purple and they swole up like
it's swollen up like twice the size of
normal.
What I don't understand,
I don't understand how the
guy can physically take it.
Which I didn't do.
I have what?
Do have any photos?
I would have taken a
photo of the batch of it.
I was only like 16 or 17 they physically
tell like cause like that obviously a
fee where you like ha like
oh it was fucked up man.
I been kicking the balls
and it's like I can't even,
I wouldn't be able to like if there was
a second kick I would just shit myself.
I got a boner on the way home though,
so I was happy.
I was happy that it still worked.
It was almost like my body was letting
me know my way because that was when I
was like,
when I was like 16 or 17 I want to get
those random boners I could be walking
and it was just kid a complete
hard on like out of nowhere.
What the fuck is this doing here?
It's cool too.
You didn't know.
It's like given a blind person that gun.
Like what is,
what is this a trigger?
I don't know what you're
doing and when you're,
when you're a 17 year old kid
just walking around with a boner.
I would crank out so many fucking always
horny and like that that chamber is
fucking reloaded immediate immediately.
And what's really fucked up is that
that is probably like one of the biggest
shifts as a human being that your
life makes from no sex at all.
To boom.
Having a girlfriend when you
were in your teenage years,
which are confusing.
It's fuck yeah.
I mean your teenage years are on mass and
in that you were having relationships.
You're making it out with people and
young penises going into girl's vagina.
It's the best you've
ever felt in your life.
And she's on the pill so
you can squirt it in her,
I guess.
So confused.
He gets so baffled.
You're so fucking twisted.
Just so absorbed in that person.
And that's why you see
so many people that age,
like throw everything else away for
that relationship because they can't.
It's all so addict behavior.
Yeah.
We've all been guilty of it.
Sure.
Addict behaviors.
Not just physical addiction.
It's just like squirly thinking,
you know,
no addict behavior.
It's like some,
there's a lot of like different activities
that shouldn't really exist for our
shitty minds,
but they do exist and people can't
help because of the fact that they have
access to casinos.
There's certain people that cannot fucking
hell bet they're drawn in there and
gamble.
They want to,
that's what they live for.
It's it's,
I've seen it.
It's craziness.
And they'll go on these programs now.
I'm not gambling anymore.
I'm not doing this anymore.
I'm done.
Then next thing you know,
and I'm just going to try it a little,
I could handle it now.
It's all about management.
Boom,
back in the slide.
Crazy in debt.
Never get,
and it's not,
it's just no,
just no drugs.
There's no dealer,
there's no no poisoning.
There's just fucking do this weird idea
that you need to fucking pull that lever
and see those lemons.
You so glad I don't have that.
Oh,
and then they take that
money and go right back in.
Was fucking horrified.
It was a guy named White Plains Charlie
when I was a kid and I used to play pool
at executive billiards.
He was the first guy that ever met
was an absolute 100% gambling junkie.
This guy didn't do a goddamn thing for a,
and he lived off of handouts
and games who hustled pool.
He slept in like homeless
shelters and the,
you know,
in different people's houses and you know,
had apartments in like real,
real squirrely situations and he would
just come down the pool hall and go to
the race track and
that's all this guy did.
That's all this guy did.
He was always in action.
He was always an action component and it
was so sad guy cause he was in his like
seventies you know.
And he was like,
you know,
just a really tiny,
tiny man and people would yell at 'em
and they'd fucking treat him like shit
cause he was always broke and he would
yell at them and he would always loses
money.
Those guys almost had those motherfuckers.
I'm supposed to have seven,
seven a fight and you know,
we'd have some number of
problem that went wrong on.
Of course,
I know that would have paid two thousand
two thousand can you believe that?
Shit.
I can't tell you how many conversations
I had with White Plains Charlie.
Well,
he would come in there and go,
Joe,
you ain't going to believe this.
That got me out the track again.
I'm down and I was,
I was like at the time,
maybe 22 to 23 years old,
so the whole thing to me was
just completely baffling.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's out of his
fucking head for sure.
This is crazy.
He just can't stop gambling.
I've never seen anything like it.
I know it could.
Poker guy like that who just can't stop.
They can't stop and sweaty hands.
I,
I was completely addicted to play in
that quake game a hundred percent 100% I
loved it.
Loved it,
Dubbed the hours and hours a day.
If you were talking and I'm listening to
you talk and you're boring the shit out
of me and be like,
why am I spending time doing this when
I can be playing quake and my time would
be awesome as always,
really I would not want to talk to people.
I would want it to sit in front of the
computer with the headphones on because
you could hear like who's
walking on the right hand side.
Really like footsteps on the
right or footsteps on the left.
You have to,
you have to creep because if you
walk you don't make any noise.
But if you want to jump,
if you want to strafe jump.
If you want to run,
you make noise.
Yeah,
and I would get addicted dude.
Wander down hallways,
rocket launcher and people in the heads.
It's fun.
I've been lost in video games
before to addict behavior.
The real problem is it doesn't make you
ultimately feel like you got anything
done.
Like if I put the same amount of effort
into making podcasts or the same amount
of effort into like doing stand up,
I feel like I got something done,
you know?
But if you're just out there fucking
throwing squares with numbers around,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
You playing cards?
Just nothing actually happening.
He playing quake.
I fucked him.
Killed everybody that
nothing really happened.
No.
Okay.
You just got,
you just got jolted,
nothing was really created an eight hours.
You basically gave all your time,
you know,
to this uh,
this artificial experience and you know
you've got an adrenaline rush out of it.
It was a lot of fun.
It was great but,
but ultimately nothing was created.
Whereas like if you took that same
amount of time and you decided to,
I'm going to draw a picture,
I'm going to paint something,
I'm going to write a song like an actual
physical thing manifests itself that
people can enjoy or
fucking rocket launches.
Lightening Bolt guns and
shit gunning people down.
Hey low.
You don't get anything out of that.
It's weird that your
game halo you used to be.
I tried to,
I step away.
I literally forced myself not to get on
game systems that much anymore cause I
would,
I would do that and I would do a
Madden and NCAA most to be awesome.
The mad
cause I liked college ball a lot.
I would play,
you could create a player,
you start your team
and then play a season.
Did you make white guys?
When I would make,
I would make fucking Tom run at 43 44
it would give them ridiculous power.
Absolutely.
I'd be like Vikings three
two 30 just fucking yoked.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Just Vikings,
Vikings,
army of Brock Lesnar's the full,
I would say I would play,
I would do the spring thing,
spring ball and then play fucking 12
games season that the conference game and
the in the bowl game.
And then recruit players for that cause
you can recruit and recruit them for the
next year and fucking,
I'd played,
you know,
14 games in a row and I'm like holding
on for the next season to start.
And this is like in one city.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hours and hours.
It's not good man.
Well that's the same thing with poker too,
right?
I mean,
when people start playing poker,
don't they disappear?
Absolutely.
And the guys that,
the guy that I know that,
that,
that does it the most,
like not only did you disappear
and doing all that behavior,
but he's also fucking
losing his livelihood.
You know,
like Shit fucking down 500 today.
So art,
it's hard to make a living playing poker.
You mean you gotta be super good?
You mean all props to those Daniel and
the Granola type characters that have
been noon,
Phil Ivey and all these guys
that you like to hear about?
I don't play it.
Um,
I don't like cards.
It's not that I don't like cards,
it's just,
it's not something that I'm interested
in doing because when I was a a kid and I
would play pool,
the card games would always
interrupt the pool action.
Oh really?
And everybody would like Jesus Christ.
Is this a card place or a pool hall?
Like guys that what you
would normally get bets with?
They wanted to go gamble because
that's all pool halls were about.
All pool halls were about what?
It's like hobby people who were into a,
just knocking balls around with
their friends who never got good.
And then either tournament
players are gamblers.
And so the tournament players are usually
both porn meant players and gamblers.
So there's always gambling unless of
asshole came around with a deck of cards
because you can't,
you don't,
you can miss when you're playing pool,
you know,
you can mess,
you can hit play on a Gaffey table
where the pockets are weird and this guy
might know the table about it than you do.
So he knows what spots to avoid.
But with poker you can't eat,
does no missing.
You just,
you're really gambling,
you're just gambling.
You know,
you're,
you're using your intelligence
but also gambling.
I don't get poked in the,
I'm of the mind for it,
man.
I'm really powerful.
CTO,
coconut water.
Thank you very much.
I'm not into it man.
Let me see.
Emanated by numbers
and I'm intimidated by,
um,
just like the game itself never been,
was like an awesome game.
It seems like a,
a real absorbing game though.
It seems like a very,
like you have to really be a,
a bad motherfucker to understand the
in and outs of poker and to have like,
you know,
years and years of intuition.
I mean those are special dudes.
They,
they obviously have special mines.
Just for me,
my,
I was always so absorbed with
things that required execution,
physical execution as well as like mental.
And that's why I liked quake cause it was
like this hand eye coordination thing.
That was what I was
getting my rocks off on.
And that's the same thing with pool.
So to me it's like it was always a
physical thing as well as a mental thing.
I felt like the real,
the real thrills to me,
well when I can combine
the two things together,
when I could combine a physical
experience and a mental experience.
That's why I liked Jujitsu.
That's why I like playing pool.
So the card thing was lacking.
The physical part,
there's no execution.
I didn't have to execute.
So that was,
it was like way less exciting.
I was like,
you can't compare the difference between
when you're watching a guy gambling and
his gambling for $10,000 a set of nine
ball and every fucking pocket he's
putting his hands on his shirt and blow
it on his hands and put talcum powder on
and he's sweating and he's
trying to keep it together.
You're trying to like really gently
control how ball spins and collides with
another ball and you know,
make sure that you hit it just enough
so that lands perfectly for the next one
all while you're gambling,
you know?
I mean that's what,
what's exciting when you're just
sitting there with cards and you,
you know what card to pick stupid.
Just pick the fucking card.
It's like you win or you don't when it's
like it's not the same loss you guys
shoots your nuts in and the game of pool,
I'll give you a plan.
10 year plan to race to 10 and he breaks.
It runs out 10 games on you,
you lose.
You don't even get a chance to
play like that can't happen.
That has happened.
It really not to me,
but it has happened in
the past 10 in a row.
Just run.
The things happen more than once.
There was a one guy who
did it for $1 million.
Cool.
Yeah.
They had an insurance policy
to a c who could a run.
If you could run 10 racks in a row,
which has never been done
in the competition before,
you could win $1 million.
They'd only been done
like a couple of times.
Like Johnny Archer ran 10 and out on
Francisco Bustamonte there were gambling.
And that was like a legendary
story because Francisco
Bustamante doubled the bet
after Johnny Archer ran 10 and out on him.
And he was like,
this guy can't keep this shit up.
Doubled the bat.
And then in the next game,
which is really nuts.
And then the other one was
this Earl Strickland guy who,
uh,
they had this 10 rack thing where
they were insured for 1 million bucks,
but the insurance company didn't want
to pay because they couldn't believe it.
It had been done.
They couldn't believe like they,
they found the statistics.
No one had ever broken,
run out 10 racks ever in any,
you know,
modern nine,
that ball tournament that
they could have on record.
So they said,
listen,
I don't think it's much of
a gamble bet $1 million.
If someone does it,
they win $1 million or else trickling
did it the first fucking tournament they
had.
I think it was the first,
it was either first this
second he broken ran 10 racks,
like a demon fired in
combinations on the nine ball.
I mean it was ridiculous shit.
It was like movie shit.
I am,
they denied him.
I think he wound up settling but
he never got like the full million.
I'm really,
I think he only got like a quarter
million bucks or something like that.
I hope I'm wrong,
but he's like one of the greatest
players of all time and uh,
and you know,
and he gambles too.
He does like those action challenges.
There's a action report
matches where they uh,
they have um,
uh,
online del La have like just two
guys playing for like 25,000 bucks.
I'm like put up the
money and then they'll,
they'll have like a gambling contest.
You ever played a,
what's the other one called?
Sneaker?
No,
I've never played that
same principle but smaller.
Well,
um,
it requires uh,
some incredible fundamentals.
You,
there's more room for error in a game
pool then there is and snuck her first of
all because the nine ball,
like the chosen gambling game,
nine balls,
the balls are all wild.
So what that means is if you miss the one
ball in the corner pocket but it spins
around and lands on the side,
it's still counts.
You just,
you keep going.
When snuck her,
I don't think that would ever count.
I think sneakers like very precise,
you know,
I think,
and you have to move balls.
I don't really totally
completely understand it and
the tables fucking huge and
the balls are tiny and the pockets are
tiny as shit and there's certain ways we
shoot it.
It doesn't accept the ball the same way.
It doesn't pull a table.
Like I don't think you can cut a ball
down the rail the way you can on a,
on a,
on a regular pool table.
So it's,
it's,
it's a little bit of a
different sort of a game.
But snooker players
notoriously are good at pool.
They,
uh,
like some like the top world snuck
players like these English guys and killed
Steve Davis.
Yeah.
They,
these uh,
these guys are awesome
snugger players like world,
you know,
world champions and they come over and
a pool and then eventually they start
Rodney O'sullivan and eventually
I start fucking up the Americans.
Really?
It takes time.
Yeah.
Well the Americans,
there's um,
this is like a few high level guys,
but um,
the European guys have such a strong team.
Man.
It's like there's so many guys like the,
the Americans might have like
the best guys of all time.
Like Johnny Archer,
one of the best guys of all time,
Earl's trickling when the
best guys of all time.
Shane van Boning one of the best guys of
all time and one of the best guys right
now.
But Europe is like,
there's so many fucking
players that are killers.
Rear Sump,
many pool is huge over there.
Man.
It's weird how many good guys in Asia,
they say an Asia,
like there's parts of Asia.
We're pool is fucking enormous.
The Philippines especially,
it's enormous.
Like you'd go there.
It's like one of their most,
they're like number one,
um,
behind soccer I think.
I think at soccer they're the
Philippines in the soccer.
Does that make sense?
Or is it baseball?
What am I,
am I knickers?
Maybe.
I know we're just making shit up.
Bace no.
Well,
I mean,
I slip and slide.
I'm amazed by how sports
like culturally like evolve.
Well also how certain places like so love
a sport and do not give up fuck about
another sport.
Like cricket would be a
great example of like,
it's big and some of the islands,
it's huge in India.
Pakistan,
um,
Australia,
I mean,
that shit is like,
is it a gambling game?
Is that why it's big?
I don't know if it's a gambling game,
but like you watch it and I'm like,
I don't what the fuck's going on?
And clearly nobody in this country
who's not from one of those countries,
like nobody gets,
I don't know the rules.
It's,
I think it's difficult to follow.
Like you see the number,
you're like,
what?
And it's like a five day game,
you know,
you don't understand why
they're selling pass.
I never do cocaine.
I just,
I can't get into it.
But you know,
same thing.
Billiards,
soccer,
football,
like those are very regional specific.
Well I think you get into a game
and then once you get into it,
you understand the skill behind
it and then that's what you,
you know,
look,
it's so weird.
And people were willing to
fall into things so odd.
Just look at the way
baseball uniforms look like.
What the fuck are you dressing?
Like why do you have to translate
that for this stupid game?
You're dressing like you
live in a different century.
What kind of stupid button
up shirt or you Wang,
what the fuck is with your socks?
What the fuck is with your tight pants?
If you were just a regular dude walking
around with those pants and then street,
I'd say get the fuck away from my kids.
Yeah,
but because you're
playing some silly game,
you have to dress like a,
a pilgrim.
This is ridiculous.
This game's retarded beyond belief.
I know it needs to be revamped.
It's like one step away
from a pirates fucking out.
It's ridiculous and
it's a ridiculous game.
It's just fucking boring as shit.
It takes too long.
I can't do it.
I've never had to do it.
I liked it.
I like playing it when I was a
kid and when you like playing it,
you understand what the
skills involved and you know,
hitting a 94 mile an hour fast ball or
fucking really skilled but catching a
ball that's like over the
fucking top of the wall.
But who cares?
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't like baseball.
I like football by far.
My favorites like woman's softball.
Sports are awesome.
I'll tell you what,
man,
anything that's hard is awesome.
Anything where you get into it and
you try to express yourself and,
and you know and show your,
your ability to concentrate and focus
through a ball or through whatever the
fuck it is that you're doing in any sport.
I love watching it.
I love watching competition.
I love watching.
I love watching people,
but pay off like a hard work paying off.
That's like,
to me,
I want to see that shit all the time.
Even tennis,
I don't give a fuck about tennis,
but I watched some tennis the other day.
I just watched it.
I was like,
whoa.
That guy's really trying to hit that ball.
And he's really trying to get,
oh,
he's real close and pressed.
I don't really give a fuck what's
going on because it's not my thing.
But if I was a tennis head
instead of a pool head,
it's the same thing.
It is.
It's easily gotten hooked on
tennis or baseball or golf.
This is a fucking era.
A golden era for tennis too.
Isn't bad motherfuckers playing really?
Fuck.
Yeah.
I mean,
who's that guy?
The guy that beat Serena and um,
the other one was,
what are the other,
the other William's name?
Viness.
Yeah.
Being a sensory and he beat them both.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
After he played,
he played golf,
drank beer,
and then,
uh,
played,
one,
one seven to one,
or whatever.
The fuck this really,
yeah.
Beat them both.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'll do that.
I'll do it.
I'll pull it up.
It's a famous case.
Federer is,
you know,
like,
just amazed.
Like he'd be looking at his,
he's like one of the
all time best right now,
right by far.
Yeah.
He's,
um,
he's like,
they could put him up there with
Mcenroe and as proud of those guys,
he devastated and crabs dominates people.
That's amazing.
And he's been doing it
consistently now for just years.
Men and the dog is also up there.
And uh,
what's his name?
Just retired,
uh,
Roddick and everybody was like,
if his peer class wasn't so good,
he would be,
he would have won so many more titles,
but he's just happens to be around,
uh,
in this era of like so many,
just absolutely dominant tennis players.
Yeah.
I don't follow it enough,
but I would assume that that's just
the case with everything right now.
Right.
I mean,
like some of,
in the case of basketball towns,
like here's an example of one where
it's not like the heavyweight boxing
division.
So people say this is just the,
an era where it's not as,
as competitive and as big.
There's not as many big exciting fighters.
So,
you know,
we don't talk about right now
as being the most exciting time.
And I mean,
you know,
boxing in general has taken a dip,
but like people have always been drawn
to the heavyweight division in boxing.
You know,
it's the most,
it's the one that,
that people always like big,
you know,
so the heavyweight boxers right now,
I guess you could,
the Klitschkos,
the Klitschkos can pretty much own it.
I mean,
part of that you could argue that hey,
they're not American.
So Americans get excited about
American heavyweights basically.
And those guys have been dominant.
They're not American,
but you know,
the division pretty much has a lot of
journeymen and they go up and they give it
a shot.
And sometimes the belt switches hands,
but it's pretty much the Klitschkos to,
to run through.
And people don't talk about this.
I was like,
wow,
this era right now,
you know,
heavyweight boxers,
not a great area.
It's not a great area.
I know it's not a like a Holyfield
or Lennox Lewis and there's,
and there's,
and then like another guy would pop up.
But you know,
beau would pop in and you'd be like,
Oh shit,
who's this guy?
And it's weird,
the two white guys are running shit.
Ronnie White Russian dudes
who are doctors this,
uh,
running shit.
They tell you,
I went to this,
I went to this boxing gym in,
uh,
in Glendale and it was a guy there who
was like trained a bunch of them and he
said basically like those
guys they train like,
all right,
a thousand right?
Crosses like,
yeah,
they're willing to do some shit.
Then like if someone comes in not
knowing that to start that shit over.
And so like technically every punch
is always exactly like executed,
like never off.
You'd watch them.
It's just like,
it's perfect execution,
but it's not exciting before
anybody has a chance to get good.
They nip them,
go get them quick before he gets sit
as a guy becomes he remotely and the
contention and the guy,
the trainer guy was like,
he's,
he's foreign.
So he has this heavy accent.
And he's like telling me about like,
different,
he's like,
no.
Have you ever fight with a Mexican?
You know,
they're like dogs.
They just go into a fight,
fight,
fight.
I'm like,
okay.
I was like,
do you tell everybody that?
He's like,
fuck dude,
it's such that foreign mindset.
This is no,
this is just how it is.
Just racism was,
and just like,
he's like,
Dad,
you gotta take a Mexican doubt
cause they'll never stop fighting.
And I'm like crying.
And then he was like,
the blacks,
oh please,
just great.
You know,
like,
like fighting black house.
No,
he was like,
they're just the,
you know,
like,
he's like a,
he was talking about Floyd
and he was just like,
you know,
um,
technically,
just had fantastic puncher
like Floyd Mayweather,
just everything perfect.
Perfect.
But on top of that has out of control,
reflexes skills and providing skills.
And he fence trained perfectly.
I mean,
his brother Roger,
you know,
Roger,
Roger May,
whether it was a fantastic boxer,
his dad was a good box.
Talk about Victoria teas.
That was the best sound bite ever from 24,
seven.
That thing was so ridiculous,
that fight,
that fight was so ridiculous.
He sucker punch that dude.
Guys look at the referee and he's like,
bitch,
we still fight and correct.
Blam weird of Ortiz though,
too silly.
So,
and then he kind of gave it up,
but then like we talked about,
um,
what's his name?
Uh,
I liked the way Victoria t's fights on,
man,
that guy's crazy.
Yeah,
he's a tough guy.
Just messed up.
He just made an error.
What's the Filipino?
I can't even think right now.
Uh,
you know,
so who's the many backyard pack?
Yeah.
Um,
I would like,
you call it the Filipino,
uh,
one of the greatest boxers in the history.
Maybe the greatest accomplishment,
but he,
you know,
like he leaves the ground like,
Oh yes.
Rose's legs and his punches.
Fucking powerful.
Ooh,
he hits so hard.
A lot of his power comes from his legs.
He's a powerful dude.
Manny packer.
I was a fucking murderous puncher.
He,
he,
when he fought,
um,
what the fuck's his name?
Um,
the two d broke both his eye sockets.
It Margarito.
Yeah.
Antonio,
the guy who was disgraced for
use plaster and his knuckles.
Yeah.
Boy,
he paid that price.
Karmic Karmically,
he paid that price man cause Paki I'll
beat his fucking eyes and he beat his eye
so bad they had to replace the Lens
in his eye with an artificial lens.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Have fight again.
Yup,
man.
Fuck yeah,
he did.
Yeah,
he got back in there.
Jesus Christ.
We got back in there and fought Miguel
Cotto and Miguel Cotto was one of the
guys who he beat or they suspected they
did something to his gloves because he's
fucked a dude up.
Like murderously fucked him up and he
never really did that with anybody.
Like he was just knocking
motherfuckers out cold.
Cadeau no.
Now Margarita before they found the
plaster in his gloves because he did it to
Cota though,
right?
Yeah,
he did.
He did the first time,
but the second time Codo stopped him.
But it was a,
I think it was like a cut or
some shit that stopped him,
but Margarito uh,
couldn't,
couldn't really hit as hard after
they caught him with the plaster.
That was scary shit to think that
a guy was like making his career.
He put rocks in his gloves put up.
I mean dickhead.
Yeah,
he's not,
he's totally cheating.
Yeah.
And getting away with it and giving you
like definitely fucking more aggravated
brain damage than you would be getting.
You know what I mean?
He's hitting you with
fucking casts and your faith.
Yeah.
Like that's really shaking
up the inside of your head.
There was a fight during the,
I think it was the 80s
where a guy had pulled,
Panama,
Lewis had pulled the stuffing out
of a guy's and I remember that.
And it was this kid,
I believe the kid's name was Louie Resto,
the boxer.
And then the other one was Billy Collins.
I think it was,
I forget,
I forget what the guy's name was,
but the poor kid had like
ended his career and the the,
cause he just got bare knuckle the dice.
Yeah.
Well he crashed into a tree.
They think he committed suicide.
And the guy,
Panama Red was,
uh,
Panama Lewis Lewis was,
was,
was suspended like years.
The fighter,
I don't think he ever fought again.
And he denied any wrongdoing
until a few years ago.
And he,
he gave it up on camera.
Really?
Yeah.
The boxer,
which fight about the fight
that you're talking about.
What they found that right away though.
But the box,
the guy that was guilty
of like the guy who,
who Panama was training.
Yeah.
I believe it was Louie Resto.
He,
he denied it and was like,
I didn't,
he didn't know that.
He didn't know exactly
like it was an accident.
And so that's silly and you would
fail the first punch you through.
His family always had his back.
Like they were like,
you know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't on him.
And then on camera with his family there,
he was like,
no,
I know what I did.
Oh,
they're just devastated.
Yeah.
That's a terrible,
terrible,
terrible thing to live with,
man.
That's not just cheating.
That's like,
ugh.
That's horrific man.
You basically,
you know,
you ruined the guys life.
Yeah,
you did.
It ruined the guys life.
A guy who was really good at competing
under a set of rules and you just fucking
totally hijacked the whole thing on TV.
You stupid fuck on TV.
Beat a guy up with no,
no padding and your gloves.
So you just bare knuckle
cranes and you cheated.
You cheat and asshole.
Isn't it crazy that you still get all
these guys every single year in every
sport that
all still cheat.
And you know the
big slate,
they took some,
I forget some,
somebody metal was,
you know,
one guy had marijuana in his system.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The motherfucker had
weighed in the system.
Yeah.
Some ski or some Shit.
Ah,
that's not,
well,
let's get your eye.
Can See someone who got kicked
off the team for weed was a judo.
There was a judo guy,
was a judo guy,
got kicked off [inaudible] shit.
You're like,
how are you still like,
you know,
they're gonna come after you,
man.
There's a lot of different
shit that people are doing
that they've got away with
in the past,
I think.
And they're slowly starting to clamp
down on that thing and fucking Armstrong.
Well,
this isn't,
well,
the crazy thing about Armstrong
is he's only done by this one.
Like it's an American thing
that's gone after night.
It states anti-doping and it was fucking,
but that has nothing to do
with the Tour de France.
So when they say that he doesn't have the,
uh,
the eight toward the France,
notice how I say France?
Yes.
Sophisticated.
I've been to the airport in Patti
Sharp Balto what they're saying that
jurisdiction they do.
I thought so because I mean,
everything that I saw was,
he was stripped of his title is I heard
that he was stripped by these people,
that they don't recognize it,
but I don't know if he's
necessarily stripped by the,
the,
whoever the fuck puts on the Tour de
France definitely did what they said he
did.
You think so look up guns.
Hundred percent.
I do not believe in these witch hunts for,
for like people that are essentially,
uh,
like heroes and super like nobody accuses,
um,
you know,
Michael Jordan of having done this.
Nobody.
A clique accuses,
um,
you know,
Joe Montana of having done this.
They do it because it's there.
His teammates have all come,
come clean about it.
They've also,
we all did this shit,
everybody.
And then when you
finally have your chance,
you finally have your chance to be like,
this is the last.
He's like,
you know what?
Enough's enough.
Really,
enough's enough.
That's the,
I'm just tired of fighting this fight.
Well,
you have a chance now.
This is your fine.
This is the,
like the final lap of the,
of the race.
This is when you go,
I'm just,
you know what man?
At some point,
well he's been in his defense,
he's been defending it for years.
But you give up and let
them take your name.
And while you're doing,
know that he has passed,
and I'm just playing
devil's advocate here,
but do you know that
he's past like 500 drugs?
Yes,
I do.
But why?
Why is there a witch hunt
to get somebody like that?
I don't,
I don't lose,
this is what,
what gets me,
you ever see a dude is like
killed his wife and he's on the,
he's on the news and
they're a accusing him of,
uh,
of,
you know,
like,
why'd you do it?
Why'd you do it?
And it was like I didn't,
didn't do anything.
And you're like,
that is not how you would react if your
wife was killed and they were dragging
you off and you were innocent.
You would be freaking the fuck out.
Like what?
You lost your loved one.
You're a crazy person.
You're a crazy person that
they caught doing something.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
but like you think that they
would go after him though if he,
if there wasn't any
evidence to support that.
I don't know.
Like,
like how,
no,
I'm saying like,
do you like for Lance,
right?
I mean I don't know what they can do.
I mean I think once he's
passed the drug test,
he passed like 500 fucking drug test.
But here's the thing,
where's the evidence?
What do you have?
Do you have any of his blood and you can
run it through a machine and find some
shit that we didn't find before.
Is that if you don't have
that then what are you doing?
I think they do have a,
have they do have that.
That would be no,
they would have said they had that.
If they do have that,
they would have put that shit on the news.
They would tell you what it is.
It's not something that
you can keep a secret.
They have some sample,
cause some sample was referenced with
some sample reference because he tested
positive for EPO.
Was it that,
I feel like you got tested
positive or something,
but whatever the fuck it is,
you would,
you should have either got him back then
or you need to let it go and realize
that now with your new super
sophisticated methods of,
of testing,
he might not pass those tests before.
But guess what he did
let's fucking move on.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
leave the guy alone.
I mean,
you're going to ruin his life because
he did exactly what everybody else did.
He just was better at it.
Cause that's what happened.
So,
but around you gotta be,
you have to assume that
he's a real motherfucker.
But here's my question.
Why did they,
why does he have to tell
anybody that he was,
if they were all doping?
Okay.
And that's what we're
assuming that's the case.
We're assuming that everyone
at the top of the list,
and by the way,
a lot of the doping does not
necessarily even have to be unhealthy.
Like the blood transfusions.
That's not unhealthy.
Blood doping is not unhealthy.
It just is an unknown,
an inordinate amount
of blood in your body.
You have a much more easy
way of producing oxygen.
You A,
you can process oxygen better.
That's why being dehydrated
it's so bad for your cardio.
It's like one of the most
important things for,
you know,
outdoor exercise.
Well that was,
um,
I think,
uh,
that was a fuck.
How would it,
how would they describe it?
It's,
um,
I,
I just don't think any of them can
achieve the highest level without doing at
least some of that.
If it's not blood doping,
if it's not taken EPO,
if it's not taking,
you know,
some fucking routes that boost your
testosterone that are illegal today but
won't be legal in six months from now.
When they find out about it,
there's a,
it seems like if everybody is doing
it at the very top of the list,
if the all those guys
on his team got busted,
I can only make sense
that he could do it too.
I just think that for me,
the assumption that I make,
and I again I realized that I'm not
privy to any of the like evidence or
information,
but the assumption that I make is
if all these guys say he did it,
that he worked with all
his former teammates.
Do they just associates?
Everybody says that and then the,
the,
the doping organism.
Our agency is so adamant
about pursuing it.
Like what?
Why?
Why would you do this if
there's nothing there,
why are you trying to get the like
Pete generally that doesn't happen.
People don't go after
somebody just because,
do you think that's because
like prosecutors sorta get
a wild hair across their
ass.
They're like,
we're going to go get this guy and
then it becomes like a competition.
They could be it.
That's definitely possible.
And they get,
they get,
you know,
they,
that that obviously happened like in
that Duke Lacrosse case where the,
the,
uh,
the prosecutor there was like,
he made a fucking show of it.
Like we're going to before
even like reviewing a what,
like the information and the evidence
and then he paid a huge price because he
was boasting and trashing them before
they even got in a courtroom and ended up
fucking losing his license to practice.
But I think part of that,
what he did before was from that charge,
he got of like,
I'm going to put these,
these rich entitled kids,
uh,
fucking in their place,
watch this right now.
And then it came back to bite them.
So yeah,
I think there is partly for some of
that people going after the big name,
but I just don't see,
I don't see them trying to
do this to him for no reason.
I just don't see,
I agree with you,
but I don't know what the reasons are if
I felt like if the guy passed that many
drug tests.
Yeah.
I mean if and if everybody
was doing what he was doing,
if that's what they're saying,
what's he just,
was he just better in spite of the
doping was everybody was doping.
If he's the best,
he's the,
he's a super talented actor.
Clearly he's unbelievably disciplined.
So if you're telling me they all doped.
Yeah.
Is that,
isn't that not a level playing field?
It's like the baseball argument.
They're saying this is like
the asterick whatever era.
Yeah,
because like at first it was like a few
guys and then a few more and then you're
like,
hold on,
did everybody just juice for like this
five or 10 year period and it's looking
like a huge percentage where
it's not even news anymore.
Right.
When you find out that like all the,
all the big,
all the big superstars did it,
you know,
all of them.
It's crazy.
All the home run records
were broken in that era.
When you look at Mark McGuire now and
we hear him talk about it and you hear
him,
you know he just like broke down
when he was describing what he did.
He look at the best is
when you see like a,
when he was like an Oakland,
a bash brothers era and
you see him and he's like,
you know,
he's like six [inaudible] four and he
looks like a fucking pencil to that.
Did a TV show with him.
Did you really?
He was an on an episode of Hardball
Faculty of These Really Skinny Man.
He was young.
This is the pre HGH days.
He turned into a Gore Raila.
He just went crazy with that working out.
But,
but look at the dividends man.
All of a sudden he's just
playing over rising balls.
But bonds too.
When you see [inaudible] Aiko higher.
It's uniform and is a giant shit.
It's fucking big.
Conseco was,
yeah,
he's a monster suit.
I was walking,
I was working rather in the
Boston athletic club and I
was 19 and Conseco was in
town and he needed somewhere to work out
and they must have been staying close
to the Boston athletic clubs.
They came down and worked out and
that guy walked through the door.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
like on TV with their
silly 1860s outfits on.
They don't look that big.
But when that guy walked in the,
I'm like,
he's like 300 pounds.
He's fucking huge.
I mean he might not have
been 300 but he was like,
well over two 50 he was enormous.
The,
I remember the first time when I was like,
holy shit at the size of
some like fucking humans was,
I was in high school and I played in
high school football like two hours north
of Miami.
I went with a friend of mine on like a
recruiting trip with his trip down to the
University of Miami and we're standing
on the field and the players were run out
of the tunnel and I'm looking
at dudes in their chest,
like I'm standing there looking
at the numbers and I'm like,
holy fuck,
I could never play.
It's guys like this,
like dudes that were like six six,
three 30 and I was like,
these are fucking animals running around,
man.
Did people like that
exist a hundred years ago?
I don't think so.
The one of the reasons why I think they
might have like every now and then there
was a guy that was the,
the heavyweight champion.
His name was Primo Carnera and
it was all like legit giant.
He was fucking enormous.
But like the best guys me see how
big Primo coordinator narrow was.
I think he was the biggest
heavyweight champion ever.
I think up until like at
least like modern times.
Cause I think there was some fucking
giant Russian dude recently that was even
bigger than that.
But,
uh,
I think this guy lived in like the,
the fifties I believe it was.
Yeah,
he lived until 1967
so he was a seven foot one.
Oh my God.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Okay.
Now this guy,
six foot seven,
the Russian guy that I was
talking about is seven foot one.
His name is Nikolai value of,
he's seven foot one.
Holy Shit.
So these guys were giants back then,
but Carnera was only a six foot seven.
That's still a big motherfucker.
Yeah,
Jesus.
Yeah.
Up until that time he was the
tallest heavyweight in history.
And I think today like what are
the Klitschkos they're like six,
six,
yeah,
same size and dude's,
they like the same size.
So this is Primo Carnera,
but back then he was like a like a freak.
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
what was it?
I did a,
this fundraiser,
he was 275 pounds.
This guy was
naturally and he,
and he,
uh,
that,
that was like,
by the way,
the biggest size of any athlete?
Yeah.
Through like the like in the 80s,
like I remember that
like Lineman in the were
two 75 to 80 and in every team would have
like a 300 pounder and you'd be like,
Holy Shit,
they got a 300 pound on the
team and now the entire line,
what the fuck is that?
Is that human growth hormone?
What is that?
Is that steroids in the beef?
It sounds,
is that what that is?
It's standard now.
Everyone's is three 2130.
What's happening is
it's selective growing.
What is it?
Cellphones.
Is it,
this is the first couple of generations
we were really understood nutrition and
made sure the kids have vitamins
growing up and they grew to their full
potential.
Is that what it is?
Part of it is that,
I bet that has to do a lot with it,
right?
Yeah.
I think that is part of it.
And also put,
now you have this thing
where it's like you're,
they are con like there's
more education on just,
you know,
like for instance in sports everybody has,
like you can be like,
Hey,
I want to be this weight
and you're going to program,
you need fucking 300 grams of protein
a day and you need 5,000 calories.
Yeah.
You need to do this type of workout
and you're going to fucking swell up.
You know,
you can actually set that
goal and somebody can tell
you pretty much manufacture
it.
Like in knowing their,
their science,
this is what you need to do too.
If you want to obtain that
so you can execute that,
you know,
but back then they'd just be like,
oh fuck.
And I don't know.
Yeah,
there's definitely that.
Like you definitely put on
more size now than ever before.
But what,
what I'm saying is that the actual
number of giant humans has increased.
It's not just like the
ability to put muscle on,
it's like the size of people is just,
it's more common to see these Primo
Carnera guys in athletics today,
these six foot seven just
naturally gigantic human beings.
Like that's,
that's more common today.
It just is.
So what the fuck is that?
Why is it more common?
Why is there two Klitschkos there's
two giant six foot six guys or box and
everybody up these two
giant Russian dudes,
you know,
and just think about how many
of those guys exist today?
How many,
how many giant human beings are out there?
There's a dude,
um,
who fights in the UFC?
Stephan drew,
if he's fucking seven feet tall,
man.
Kids seven feet.
Yeah.
I don't even think he's 25,
seven feet tall.
Can you know the world is not designed
for you and your seven feet two man,
he's giant.
Semi shelties and other
one's seven feet tall.
Giant kickboxers Jesus Christ.
Where the,
you know this and I guarantee you
have kids that are coming up today,
the kids that are growing
up and they're going to be,
you know,
coming to fruition or a coming to a full
height rather a within the next decade
they're going to be even more giant.
It's like people are going to get bigger
and bigger and bigger till we like
start morphing,
you know,
and we start super giant.
We're going to be giants.
There's no doubt about it man.
As soon as they figure out a way
to engineer the body selectively,
we're going to figure out
what's the optimum size you
can be and people are just
going to grow to that size that like a
hundred years ago there was not a fucking
bunch of six,
six,
300 pounds people.
Do you know how much the average
soldier weighed in the civil war?
How much?
125 pounds.
Yeah.
They were tiny little dudes.
Tommy as a fifth grader.
Yeah.
That is not the same type of human being
that we have today because people were
malnourished.
Everybody's catching fucking
diseases is shit all over everything.
Babies are dying.
Nobody knows how to wash their hands.
Right.
And it's a mess.
That was a mess.
Those are tiny ass little people.
Those people lived in the 18
hundreds or a tiny ass little people.
Yeah,
we just have Gargantuan
and they're getting bigger.
These,
these Shaquille O'Neal dudes.
I did a fear factor which
Kilo Neil and I have,
I stand deck height,
fuel deal.
He's a,
he's a grown man.
I'm a grown man.
His Dick is in my face.
I mean he's just so different than me.
It's just such a great quote.
I'm standing next to him.
We,
and we do a countdown.
It's hilarious because it's me,
you know,
I was like shot,
count them down and he goes
Whoa,
Oh and you know the people
go and do their stone.
It was really cool
cause he liked the show.
So it was fun like having
him coast with me for a day,
but it's just so ridiculous.
I'm like a little child
standing next to this giant.
I have super nice guy though.
Jonathan Ogden offensive tackle,
six eight like three 40
played at and his hand.
He just like,
he just held to have my little fingers.
It was like nice to meet you and like and
like just squeezed a couple of fingers
and I realized my hand
couldn't even like get around,
like even simulate a handshake and he
also had a conversation with somebody,
like as I was talking to him,
like down here,
I was like,
yeah,
so it's cool to me.
He was like,
yeah man,
so this other,
at the end I was like,
I'm down.
I'm like,
Damn.
I was like,
hey man,
like a kid.
Like when your kid walks up to you and
they're talking to and you're talking to
another adult and you're right,
just hold on and you're talking
to the adult and they're like,
but daddy and you're like,
just hold on and you just talk over them.
He did that to me like I was a child.
I just looked up at him and I was like,
it was nice to meet you.
You're like pat at the top.
Go ahead.
Yeah,
it was dope.
It was not like a human though.
It was like a fucking superhuman.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
The variance,
you know,
how much,
how much people vary in,
in the height and size like that.
But yet we're still in the same species.
Yeah.
But a guy should kill Neil.
It's like,
it's such an extreme version of it.
Fucking huge.
It's friendly guy though.
Super,
Super Nice Guy.
Yeah.
Mike Goldberg did a whole season
of shack versus with them.
Oh yeah.
He did a bunch of cool shit.
Like that was gold box.
Oscar de la Hoya.
And you know,
it was kind of funny.
He did a bunch of different things.
I am a,
you know,
do you know the other comic Bruce Bruce?
Do you know him?
He's a big dude.
Big enormous guy.
Not that tall,
but write like 300 plus pounds.
I sat next to him on a flight.
Did I tell you this already know?
And uh,
I'd never met him before
and I recognized him,
so I was like,
hey man,
like,
you know,
uh,
I'm a comic.
And he was like,
oh yeah,
he's super fucking Nice.
And he's just this big giant looking.
Can I ask where this story goes?
Where?
Sleep apnea?
No.
Okay.
No,
it's
uh,
you know,
10 minutes into the flight,
got braids and shit.
So we get,
we get delayed and first of all,
we're flying la,
Atlanta,
and then I'm going to,
I'm going on to Lauderdale.
He's staying at,
he lives in Atlanta,
I guess.
So everybody that comes on the plane,
uh,
who's black says something
to him and I'm like,
do you like,
do you know these people?
He was like,
aw man,
these people just,
they just fans.
And I was like,
read,
like everybody on the plane has stopped
and they tell us there's a delay,
you can get off the plane if you want.
And some girl walks by and she's like,
do you need something?
And he's like,
ah,
I'd love sweet,
like a candy bar.
And then she's like,
okay.
And I'm like,
who's that?
He's like,
I dunno.
It's like,
that leads just buying you candy man.
And he's like,
yeah,
pretty much.
I was like,
okay,
whoa and sweet.
Like,
I can't tell you how sweet of guy he is.
So we're,
we get to let the girl comes back,
gives them candy.
I'm like,
I love you.
And he's like,
I left.
Thank you sweetie.
He,
she goes back,
we take off,
we started talking comedy and he's like,
I'm doing this tour with a,
you know,
I'm torn with this person and
doing shows with these people.
And I'm asking him like,
Oh,
what do you think of so and so?
And we're talking back and forth
about people and he's like,
I'm doing this show right now where I'm,
uh,
you know,
doing some theaters with Mike Epps.
I'm opening like for him
at these massive theaters.
And I was like,
Mike Epps is a funny fucking dude.
Like,
just a naturally funny guy because
we're just like talking shit.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It was like,
you know,
that guy just turned
to any situation funny.
He's like,
yeah,
but,
uh,
ain't no mother fucker
funnier than Andy Griffith.
And I was like,
what?
Like,
what'd you just say?
And he's like,
Andy Griffith.
I was like,
are you not Eddie Griffin?
Right.
Are we talking about Andy?
The whistle shit.
Yeah.
He's like,
aw man.
And I'm like,
are you serious right now?
And he's like,
you've been to Andy Griffith Museum.
I'm like,
what kind of questions that man?
Like
what kind of questions?
And he's like,
aw man,
they got the,
like the,
the car from the,
from the show,
you can,
you could sit in the car.
They have like a set,
but like with the kitchen,
they used to show the kitchen,
you can go there.
You get all the Andy
Griffith show you ever want.
I'm like,
are we in the real world right now?
And he loves any good man.
He,
I was like,
I don't think I like anything as
much as you like Andy Griffith.
He's like,
I love Andy Griffith.
And I was like,
clearly.
And he knew,
he was like,
uh,
you know,
and I'm not exaggerating.
He was like,
you know,
there was two,
uh,
black act as that ever appeared
on the Andy Griffith show.
And I was like,
wow.
He's like,
one was a February 8th,
1963.
Why the role of Tony?
Are you saying the right data?
You just know I'm making up the date,
but he knew the day lets
these people not all right.
He knew the day we're going
to heat this up on Google.
He knew the exact date and he knew the
role and the episode and then he was
like,
and the other one was April 19th,
1968 and that was when,
remember when they couldn't find the mail.
I'm like,
no,
I have not seen these episodes.
Fuck member.
When they couldn't find my mail.
I was like,
I swear to God and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Andy Griffith
is a shit man.
I was like,
Andy Griffith,
real Andy Griffin is a shotgun.
Love Andy Griffith man.
Wow.
This is a lot of people that had like
p that pay homage to the classics like
this dudes who are really get into
like old movies and shows and,
and I've met like super fans of
some things that you don't expect.
But that for me was so adolescent field.
I saw Carol Burnett the other day.
You did Dan.
She looked good.
I'm telling you man.
I mean,
I think the lady is in her late seventies.
She looked very healthy,
smiling,
laughing and talking to people.
She,
um,
that show was great.
Yeah,
it was a great show.
Well,
it's interesting.
We were,
we were talking about this the other day,
like there was like a big wave of a
woman run shows back in there in the day
with a woman was a star.
There was Laverne and Shirley,
there was Mary Tyler Moore.
There was road.
Uh,
there was a mod,
remember mod and know,
and then there's mod and
then asthma on bad on nod.
And I remember that there was a,
there was a show that was
like a big popular show.
And then there was,
um,
the older lady who used to
be a model ran the news room.
The fuck was that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Orange,
Brown,
Murphy Brown.
That boring gas hypnotic.
What did they do to get people to
watch that show for all those years?
What kind of long time?
Hypnotism
five.
Yeah,
there was a gang of them,
but I mean that the,
the era of,
um,
Carol Burnett was like,
there was a,
like Lucille Ball,
there was a bunch of them,
like really strong women
comedian presences.
It's like Dan has changed quite a bit now.
Like the role that women have on these,
like,
you know,
you have like girls like
Chelsea who have their own show,
but it's like her personality.
It's not like,
uh,
like her being the head of a sitcom.
And then there's,
I'm Whitney Whitney who had a show that
people didn't respond to that well,
but then people said,
well,
it's going to be tweaked and
they're gonna figure it out.
But she,
but genuinely people seem to like her.
She just has to find
like the right vehicle.
Right,
right.
But how many of them are there these days?
It's not,
it's not like it used to be.
Yeah.
Especially what,
well,
also where they need to,
you know,
where they're getting their shot.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
like how many,
how many people are getting the
opportunity to have their show,
you know,
because the,
because the talent,
there's still talent.
Just a bunch of talent out there.
Like you know,
there's definitely talented comics,
female male comics out there and,
but they have to get a
shot to get there show.
That seemed to be like that was an
overdrive in that era that you're talking
about if you were a women.
Yeah.
Women.
But also I think just comics too.
Like there was,
there was an era of pushing
the comic to get the show.
And here's the thing
that's funny that you,
when you like why,
how come not that many stand up,
let's say have a show right now.
Right,
right.
Like how many more?
It's like bait and extension of the comic.
You'd look back on that era and all of
those shows were hits like the standup
where the comic was elite.
A lot of those were hits,
man.
Yeah.
There was a few bombs though.
I was,
I was there for a view.
Yeah.
But there's a watched a few,
I was a part of a few that was for,
I had my own Sitcom.
Uh,
you did a pilot for NBC once.
Yeah.
It was called,
um,
overseas.
I don't even think it ever Erin anywhere.
Even as a pilot.
You shot the pilot though.
Yeah,
it was super expensive pilot.
But the,
um,
the thing about like those,
uh,
development deals I tried to do at
standups is that they would just throw a
bunch of money at a comic
and then get a bunch of like,
you know,
writers and supposedly had some success
on other shows and throw as much shit
against the wall and see
how much of it sticks.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that it's,
it's real hard for you to take the one
thing that you're fucking awesome at,
which is stand up.
The one thing that you
really quick and complete,
express yourself.
You're uncensored,
you're,
you're producing it,
you're directing it.
Nobody's interfering with your,
your vision of how the
joke should play out.
And there's a big difference between
that and being on a set comp set and that
that difference is
it.
There's a,
it's really fun being on a good Sitcom.
It's terrible being on a bad sitcom.
It's terrible.
And it's not as,
Mo is not as much fun and it's
not as rewarding as doing standup.
It's just not,
you know,
for me at least it's like a,
it's fun doing like a cool sitcoms.
But if I had a choice between watching
like the best sitcom ever or watching
Richard Pryor do stand up,
I want to watch Richard Pryor.
That's the best stuff.
The best stuff is stand up.
So it's like you,
you do shit that's not as good as the
best stuff and it's just because they're
paying you to do it.
That was how I was feeling about it.
And the thing that you don't really love
to do and that they're paying you to
do,
it takes all day and then you don't have
as much energy or time leftover for the
thing that you do love to do.
And I can see that.
So the only reason why you should do
it is to get exposure for your standup.
Yeah.
Which I hear it like,
I mean some of the comics that
really alike doing comedy,
doing standup,
that's generally what you hear them say.
It was like it's just going to
drive more people to see my show.
Yeah.
That's how it should be.
That's how it should be,
man.
That's how it should be.
It's a,
the art of standup comedy,
he didn't get any respect for
awhile in the 80s I think as a,
as an end destination
because everybody was like,
you gotta get a Sitcom,
you gotta get a Sitcom.
That's what Jerry Seinfeld did.
This guy did the pilot in
terms of like your career,
like I did it in the
middle of news radio alarm.
It'll all,
I was doing news radio.
Yeah.
Cause it was the same producer.
So seed that and that's shelf
spoiled his shit out of me man.
Because they were so good.
The writers were so good
and they were crazy.
They would,
they were so nuts.
They wouldn't even start a script
till like two o'clock in the morning.
Sometimes,
and they would,
she would show up and it would
be like tape day or a rather,
um,
a rehearsal day and we would get like
the first 30 pages and they're like,
or the first five pages
or whatever it was,
they're like,
we're going to give you the rest later.
And then a scene two would come down
at noon and they would shuffle down
barefoot and slap it down.
They'd go back and they would,
they would get to this state of sleep
deprivation and come up with this really
silly shit.
And I suspect it was because nobody had
informed them about the benefits of we'd
really,
I think if those guys were stoners,
they weren't stoners and those
are the guys were stoners.
What they did sober was brilliant.
You know,
if they,
if those guys were high,
they could have come up with the most
silly and ridiculous show in the history
of the universe.
How many seasons was that Sean,
for five seasons.
Five.
Yeah.
That was a longer,
even now it was just too
short of a syndication,
like the normal syndication length.
Oh,
Mitt isn't syndicated.
it isn't,
but it's to,
to,
to episode short,
we only did 98 instead of a hundred.
And you're supposed to have a
hundred so that they could sell it.
Yeah.
But it didn't become popular
until after it was canceled.
Really?
Yeah.
Became popular when it would air
on TV during like regular TV time,
like seven o'clock and eight o'clock and
late night and shit like that when it
was syndicated and then people will like,
this show's kind of fucking funny.
Yeah.
It's just gotten monkeyed
around back then,
man.
Back in the day when
when news radio was out,
nobody knew where the fuck you where
if they moved you from like Monday to
Wednesday,
you're done kid.
Nobody knows.
The other thing,
like more to your point about the,
uh,
you know,
when you're just in charge
of your standup shows,
man,
you're talking about so many
people are giving their input.
You know,
like the executive producers,
writers,
like so many people,
we should really do this.
We should really lose that.
Well,
I don't like it when
you come out that way.
I don't,
I don't like it.
When you do that,
I don't like it when you,
Oh stop please.
I don't care.
We can only do this one way and the only
way I'm going to get advice as is from
funny people.
I can't get advice for someone
who's a business person.
It's like,
I just kind of tell you that.
I think that approaching it this way,
when they give you a comedy note,
that's just like,
I had a conversation with a guy and he's
talking about podcasting because you
guys have really nailed down
your brand and I'm like,
oh that's gross language.
You're grouse.
Yeah,
that's the last thing we've done.
Nailed down our brand.
He's like,
you know,
I go,
what do you mean by then?
It's like,
well you know,
people know what kind of,
you know what you're putting out there.
It's like,
you know you've really like well defined,
your,
your brand.
My brand.
What is that?
Yeah.
Fuck you talking about the edge.
It's like show Biz talk.
Well,
we're trying to,
right now we're,
we're working on is development deal,
but we just don't want
to sign with anyone.
We really want to work
on developing its brand.
Yeah.
Brand.
Are you,
are you a bottle of ketchup?
You fuck.
Define what do you need a brand?
Sorry is silly bitch.
If you're that defined you,
then you become immobile.
You become locked into an
emo Phillips type character.
Oh yeah.
Imagine going Cmo
Phillips and he drives to,
tries to do stand up and be like,
hey,
fuck head.
Why aren't you acting
like you're poised it up,
man.
We ended up,
we ended up shithead.
What's this?
You just standing there
telling me about butter.
Okay.
Get a move on with I came to see your,
your fucking funky act.
I love it man.
Well,
if you're not going to do it,
where's Judy Tenuta?
I want to see your weird shit.
Yeah.
I'm here to see your,
your whole dirt.
You ever know.
How do you go from doing that to
try to do just regular standup?
I only give him shit because I know he
tells his opening acts not to swear.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well I've heard from [inaudible].
I don't know exactly.
I wasn't really there.
They could have been a bunch
of bitter twats but uh,
I don't remember who it was.
They said they got harassed
for being too dirty,
opening for him.
Man,
that sucks.
I might've been half rotten.
I kinda wish I remember who it was,
what happened to have her,
I've had it going to
get them back in here,
man.
I've had it said passive
aggressive love half Ron for it.
I mean,
you know,
opening for somebody like say
fuck a Lotta and you're like,
Oh,
do I?
And they're like,
oh no,
no,
that's not a thing.
And you're like,
you just made it a thing because
you just hinted as a thing in um,
in Boston they used to like always decide
like headliners would decide who had
oh porn and they would,
you know,
there get him Outta here.
He breaks the fuck meter.
It was like,
that was like the big thing.
They didn't want to go on
and after anybody dirty
because if you wanted to have
any sort of shock value
to your comedy whatsoever,
but that just means your comedies on that.
Good.
Yeah,
that's how I always fell.
Sure the bass guys can
go on after Andy Body.
It doesn't matter.
I seen,
yeah,
it's just,
especially when people know who they are.
Like I got a chance to see Hedberg a
bunch of times and I saw Hedberg in front
of people who are fans and I got to see
a Hedberg in front of people who had no
idea who he was.
And it was a big difference.